dude the the how I built this episode
with haim saban a guy who did the same
thing with Power Rangers yeah I think we
talked about this that did we yeah make
sure I get his name right Haim Saban
yeah
God first of all what a charismatic dude
second of all he did this exact same
thing he went to he went to Japan saw
Power Rangers were a thing and was like
this is brilliant and brought it to the
States or just licensed the content and
the lace is the ability to dub it over
and licensed like to have it exclusively
in the states and they were like sure is
never gonna work in the States so like
try it I guess and then he just shot all
the scenes and no he didn't shoot
anything no the the American I thought
he they had to capture at least like the
American characters like in like it when
they're at school and like doing
different shake down the line but this
is like when it first came out was that
was the first season not incorporate
that I don't think I think it was
literally just the Japanese show that
they just dubbed it over oh okay I think
I would imagine they had to get a couple
scenes to set up the story maybe because
when you watch that show like Gracie was
just the action footage and stuff that
was yeah yeah I think I think that but
the the dialogue between the characters
it was like it always felt even when I
was like [ __ ] that young I felt like
this is so random yeah it's like
something was off yeah like it just like
there'll be this crazy fight inches them
at school just like hey Kimberly how are
you I'm like wait what I remember that
[ __ ] feeling when I watched Power
Rangers I'm like wait they're in school
they [ __ ] this this stinks like I
didn't like that I want them to be like
actually interesting there was
definitely something off-putting about
it that you couldn't really yeah it's
like I hate this cuz you didn't know
because it was like you didn't know you
had no concept of what dubbing was know
or like why English voices cuz they
would use the footage of them in the
Power Rangers suit talking to each other
right um know that that's the part that
was always was silent no cuz when they
were like it's morphin time their heads
always like seem to like float so I
wonder if they do like some green screen
cropping or like didn't fully like match
up yeah I mean he had to jump through
some hoops to get it to get it on
American television because everyone
this is never gonna work this is so
stupid 20,000 seasons later yeah oh yeah
guys as of the very air like from the
very first episode they put it on it
like 11:00 a.m. yeah in the summer and
they gave him like the worst slot or
something like that and right away it
was like their highest performing show
cracking yeah and then now he's a
billionaire
not from Power Rangers book from like
just being in TV business beast yeah he
bought out fox kids at one point like
just an incredible episode listen to
that bro so you know the Green Ranger
from the original cast he like went on
to become a karate instructor hmm and
then he eventually wanted to become an
MMA fighter no way yeah and bro he got
knocked out or something no he I'm not
gonna talk about MMA he Jason David
Frank JDF dude he turned to like you
remember the green rangers like this
cool like outcast guy and then you're
like wait what the [ __ ] happened to my
hero
what the [ __ ] just turn into this dude
dude it's depress the [ __ ] out of me I
was like no Smash Mouth guy dude yeah
yeah is this made me sad man
jtro he looks like mark McGrath's like
twin like no he this looks like my
grandpa mark McGrath I'm saying mark
McGrath was like the angel he would be
the devil yeah we should we should call
back Power Rangers with mark McGrath as
the lead good guy yeah and JDF comes
back as his arch-nemesis JDF so sick
they have a [ __ ] acronym kind of yeah
it kind of is so hard yeah [ __ ] jizz
destroyer ridiculous jizz domination fab
you later
it was the F stand for JDF oh did I say
art JDR JDF yeah just destroyer
fantastic all right yeah how's he
destroyed jizz he destroys things with
his gist okay all right he's the jizz
destroyer he doesn't he just didn't
destroy jizz so then he like he's does
he scream it out like an old-school
action comical character like Jews go
like spider-man but through out of his
dick okay yeah I pictured it more like a
laser no it's just it's like jizz yes
okay just comes out really hard he just
kills the vibe that's all it is yeah
there's actual superhero [ __ ] going on
and he just nuts on something everyone's
like what dude that's sexual assault
that's
[ __ ] felony what did you just do he's
not and I'm the just destroy remember
the spider Gawker whatever I don't even
want to revisit that let's just leave
that where it belongs dude anyway anyway
anyway
you